people call me a princess  but behind the palace gates and in the  shadow of my sister  the soon-to-be Queen it was me the  second born who was chosen to protect  our kingdom  good morning class we are going to have  fun this summer as members of the secret  society of second-born Royals you guys  have super powers we're superheroes  there's a special gene exclusive to  second borns of Royal bloodlines a gene  that gives some of us extraordinary  abilities  your abilities are unique to you alone  this test is designed to help sharpen  your supersenses does that involve  push-ups I have a doctor's note for that  I yeah you're definitely not gonna like  it  for thousands of years second borns like  you have protected our kingdoms from  threats he wants the throne  he's more powerful than any of us but  he's not more powerful than all of us  royalty by day  zero by night  it sounds pretty dope  where the fairy tale ends  is where our story begins  you  [Music]  you